welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilshire host and our guest is
Grace Cao who is professor of sociology
and faculty director of education
studies at Yale University she studies
race ethnicity and immigration as they
collectively relate to education and
relationships among young people she's
also interested in the effects of
migration on young people and has
written papers on these topics in Mexico
China and Spain her work has been
published in numerous scholarly
publications and according to Google
Scholar it's been cited more than 8,000
times today we'll talk with Professor
Cao about her research on the spousal
age gap in cross-border marriages
welcome professor Cao thank you so let's
talk about the paper that you wrote that
was just published in population and
development review give us an overview
of it sure so it looks at cross-border
marriages so these are marriages between
folks that are not citizens of the US
and folks who are citizens of the US so
what's interesting is that sociologists
and other demographers and social
scientists have long looked at marriage
patterns of immigrants so after they
arrived to the u.s. what we know less
about really is whether marriage becomes
an impetus for migration so we know in
the popular media there are couples that
meet abroad and also people that perhaps
travel abroad for the purpose of meeting
a spouse so we're interested in
basically how marriage and my timing of
migration overlap with each other okay
so you're looking at what countries
specifically so people coming from
Mexico or Canada from the United States
and this is people coming from anywhere
anyway yeah so there are analyses in the
paper that look at regional differences
but the the primary goal was to look at
how citizenship status overlap with the
married timing of marriage and
and also whether there's a different age
gap depending on where spouses meet
essentially okay interesting so what led
you to be interested in this so my
co-authors Kelly balistrari stamp Kelly
Stanford balistrari and Kara Joyner and
I are working on a book on interracial
romance and friendship among youth so
for that paper or that book rather we're
looking at a cohort a group of people
who are were 7th to 12th graders and we
look at how their relationships in
adolescents linked to their
relationships in young adulthood so
that's a different project and that's
the project we've been working for a
long time on in that conversation we
were reading lots of media reports about
interracial relationships and also
there's a lot of ethnographic accounts
and popular media accounts of folks that
travel abroad you know we've all heard
of mail-order brides and so far so that
got us insert about a different topic
and Kelly was really smart and figured
out a way to to look at the timing of
marriage and migration and so we thought
oh could we find folks that met abroad
and perhaps came to the US after
marriage and immediately after marriage
and so that's how we started and so I
want to give a lot of credit to to
Kelley balistrari who really figured out
how to deal with this in terms of data
issues okay and let's talk about the
methodology how did you know how did you
you know do the research for the paper
yeah so we used the American Community
Survey which is essentially something
collected by the US Census it's
equivalent to the long-form that we had
in the census before so the census that
everyone takes is pretty short and
doesn't have a lot of information so the
long form has more questions about
foreign-born status timing of migration
how long people had been in the US and
so forth so we were able to do this and
the sample we used had 90,000 women who
were married we had two
look at people who are married and
75,000 men who are married so it's
interesting that it was more women than
men
oh sure there there are okay it's partly
because that we narrowed it by age so
because if you sort of expand the age
range you hit different historical
periods so there are people who were GI
is perhaps during the Korean War who met
their spouses that way and so we wanted
to constrain the historical period
because there's a lot of events that
occur that might drive these things so
we wanted to be able to tell a clean
story okay so what time period are you
looking at well so these folks were 17
or 18 rather 235 and they had to be
married within the last ten years okay
all right so what roles do age and
citizenship play in the equation yeah so
what we found is that men and women so a
US citizen man and we only looked at
different sex marriages in this paper a
US citizen man who marries a non citizen
woman abroad either before they might
before the woman migrates or in the same
year those couples have an average age
gap about seven years so the man is
about seven years on average older than
the woman okay when we look at couples
so non citizen women that are married to
citizen men but married after the woman
migrated that gap is three years and
then we look at non citizen women who
marry someone who's a non citizen man in
the US the gap is one year so there's a
the gap is really quite large and if you
look at from the point of view of men so
non citizen men who are married to US
citizen women abroad the gap is three
years or sorry the gap is less than one
year so there's only husbands are only a
little bit older than women and then if
you look at non citizen women who are
married to citizen men but married in
the
us after a year or more of arrival the
gap is two years and so again so even
even for non-citizen men they're sort of
they have to marry a woman not older
than them but the age gap is smaller so
there's it looks like both men and women
are doing some kind of trade but the the
gap is largest for the women that are
traveling from abroad so what are you
mentioned the word trade what is being
traded right so we argue that again
previous research really looks at how
what happens after people arrive to the
u.s.
these are women by definition and men
who do not have citizenship status okay
when you marry someone who is a US
citizen it is much easier to eventually
become you know a permanent resident and
then that's a path to citizenship right
so we're arguing you know even though we
can't measure it directly that women who
marry a US citizen prior to coming to
the u.s. that this is a faster route to
becoming a US citizen so you know you
could imagine that if you come to the US
okay so let's say you marry someone from
abroad and that person is also not a US
citizen right so you're both in the same
boat to speak right so anyhow so that's
that's what we can capture we can't you
know it's it's essentially data that's
like the US Census so we're not talking
to individuals we can't measure their
actual motivations all we can do is look
at the timing of these events but we can
say this it's nationally representative
so what we're saying is true for the
entire US population okay and in terms
of people coming in from other countries
did you track that at all so where
they're coming yeah so we looked at the
the region of the world we tried to do
this by country too but the the numbers
of people get high
small but we found very big variations
and so the patterns we found are
actually consistent with some of the
media accounts so foreign-born Brides
who are who meet their spouses before
coming to the US or in the same year as
coming to the u.s. ones from Southeast
Asia the age gap is ten years okay so
they're marrying men that are on average
ten years older Russia is the next
highest region and that's about eight
years okay and so compare that to
someone who was say from Canada who is
who might meet you know their spouse
abroad and that gap is two or three
years so that's much like the gender gap
in marriage among people that are ready
in the u.s. right on average men marry
women that are a couple years younger
mm-hmm so yeah so it's a big difference
right yeah so how about I'm interested
in women who are citizens marrying men
yes from outside the country so at that
it's so interesting because at first we
didn't really think about them right so
the stereotype is men are traveling
abroad and perhaps for the purpose of
meeting women but we found also a gender
difference again it's not to the point
where women citizen women are marrying
younger men but that gap is much smaller
so they're getting they're essentially
marrying a man that's just about a year
younger and of course again the
differences are not big but that's
compared to I think on average non
citizen men that marry a non citizen
woman after arrival so let's say you're
from you're from China and you're a
single man you come to the US you meet
another non citizen let's say from China
also so that kind of couple the
difference is I think about three years
okay so that's much like the patterns we
see for the general public
in the US and that's kind of a standard
gender norm interesting so really the
year the there isn't really much of an
age gap until you have
marrying women from outside the country
right and specifically from certain
regions of the country
okay so did anything surprise you while
you were doing the research I think
sometimes for folks like me who are
quantitative researchers we read a lot
of interesting media accounts of events
and patterns and then when we dig
through the data if we have data that is
sort of parallel to that those kinds of
patterns often we don't find much
because there are lots of interesting
stories that might emerge when you talk
to a couple of people but when you look
at the national population there might
not be much happening so actually we
were surprised that our findings were so
consistent with the media accounts and
with there have been documentary films
following folks who travel abroad to
meet to meet people so we are surprised
actually to find that's a really big
difference
interesting so are you going to be
looking at the same group of people down
the road in terms of divorce rates for
instance or any is there going to be any
kind of a follow up that's a great
question for some datasets there are
large longitudinal components where they
follow the same group of people over
time and for our book that's what we're
doing that we have a data set with lots
of young people and we can follow them
over time when static collected by other
folks but with US census kinds of data
you can't do that it's not longitudinal
so it's just a snapshot of the u.s.
population at one point in time okay so
we could look at you know in 10 or 20
years whether the regional patterns hold
or whether the age gap shrinks or grows
but we can't say anything specifically
about these people I understand okay and
then so what do you conclude in your
paper so we conclude that there is
evidence especially for non citizen
women and citizen men that that meet a
bride that there is some kind of
exchange between a more youthful
partner so youthful bride for men that
are citizen citizens
so I forgot to say this that also these
men tend to be older than the typical
men who are married they tend to be more
likely to be on their second or higher
order marriage so it's a very distinct
population that that travels or maybe
they don't travel but they are abroad
when they meet their partner okay all
right this has been fascinating thank
you so much for being here with us today
thank you for speaking with me for more
information about professor Cao and her
research please visit our website at
macmillan report jled you be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]